I am low on energy. I have been doing the right energy program a couple times this past week during the nap and I've been wearing energy patches three times a week by appetite has been suppressed suppressed for a couple of weeks
except for a few days. I located the right appetite program and have now run in two consecutive days. How often can I run this daily? Okay, let's stop right there. This person is investigating the programs on his right and I commend him for that. That's just great. That's what I want you guys to do.
So I wrote those programs for your cancer that you're running nightly programs and I have some day programs for you, but that doesn't mean you shouldn't be investigating other programs and boy and I think you should be praying through those other programs and asking God what you should be ready. You cannot run too much of anything. So go ahead and run if you feel like it's helping you continue to run a program. How often can I run this program daily? Yes, you could run any of those programs daily multiple times today.
Reliefiest, which is this person named their cancer is draining a lot and it's purged to large black red dead cells. Yes, I got that photo. Thank you. Another purged on Thursday, same size, et cetera.
That is, I think very good news. Night time is not too restful for me. I'm sorry to hear that. I wake up four to six times and he suggestions to get a more restful and sleep.
You can't think about taking CBD at before you go to bed. There's another product called insomnetal that's by designs for health that has been told and to help you fall asleep, but it also has some good herbs like malaria and things that will help you just calm your heart.
Calm your body and help you stay sleeping. Also, a product that could that could just help boost your adrenal glands can help you stay a state because remember one of the things about waking up at night can be because your journals are drained and you have decreased cortisol production and decreased breakdown of glycogen stores in your liver. So that's a possibility too.
So it all depends on why you're waking up person's waking up to go to the answer that's whole different discussion. If the person's waking up because they have pain, that's another discussion if it's just because they're just not really calling it pain but uncomfortable because of their cancer that I would take the suggestions that I just mentioned something that would just some call me the herbs that may be help to the news rest and our CBD.
Two or three times due to the bathroom, so not an easy solution to that for men, you think of prostate supreme.
And also, if there is any type of bladder infection.
Then it's you want to think about treating that that can happen to two times due to crabs before going to bed once a bite, I spray liquid magnesium on my legs, that could be beneficial taking magnesium orally can be beneficial. That's where also the multivitants can be beneficial too.
And then each time I wake up in the water before going to bed, continue to lose some weight, maybe a couple of pounds, I want to work out, but sometimes I'm tired, their life just doesn't allow that.
I added kachama last week to my diet and yesterday had it two times daily.
A little worried about working out, make sure that you're just doing light workouts or light exercise, I do have a blog post on the type of exercise that person should do with cancer so look at that as well.